hi everyone I think
much for coming I'm Steve pity I'm
professor of history at American Studies
of the Center for the Study of race
indigeneity and transnational migration
here at Yale thank you everybody for
turning out for this wonderful
opportunity to hear from one of my very
favorite scholars professor Adam Union
of Stanford University
I want to thank Nandi Cummings and
others at this at the RIT M Center for
helping to put this event together and
making all of this possible Anna mignon
is assistant professor of history at
Stanford she received her BA degree from
the University of Chicago and then her
master's and her PhD the latter in 2012
from Yale's American Studies program
here in New Haven her dissertation which
is the basis for her tremendous book
from which she's speaking today and
which you can see pictured on the screen
next to me
I'm received in 2012 the Ralph Henry
Gabriel prize for as the best of
dissertation written in American Studies
in the field of American Studies in that
year Anna as you'll see today is a top
scholar of US history and of Mexican
history especially in the late 20th
century and to my mind is the finest
historian of Mexican migration working
today
she's published in the journal American
quarterly in the Journal of American
history in places like the Washington
Post and elsewhere
she's also made other important media
appearances in recent months talking
about issues related to Mexican
migration and migration in Mexico her
book undocumented lives published just
months ago by Harvard University Press
in 2018 explores the late 20th century
history of Mexican undocumented
migration in to the United States the
growth of migrant communities in the
United States and by national efforts in
the late 20th century to regulate the
us-mexico border I'm in writing this
history relies upon an incredible set of
sources of primary sources many of which
she's the first to use as a scar
she did over 200 oral histories in this
to do this project she worked with
government archives she she captured
migrant correspondence letters and also
used privately held organizational
records and personal collections
pamphlets and unpublished ephemera and
newspapers and magazines collected in
places like Washington DC Chicago the
San Francisco Bay Area Los Angeles
Michoacan Zacatecas and Mexico City what
she crafted is really the first
sustained history of transnational
Mexican migration from roughly the year
1965 to 1986 and what she does in this
book undocumented lives should I think
reset how we talk about the recent
histories of both Mexico and the United
States indeed of of governments of
everyday people of migrants and of non
migrants of what it means to be a wage
earner of what it means to be a family
member a citizen a queer subject and
much much more now in the Academy people
like me aren't supposed to have
favorites or favorite books but this
this book and this scholar the book at
least belongs on the short list the
small shelf I think of most important
books published on these subjects and on
other subjects it's one that's deserving
of all of our attention and many more
people's attention and to Ana's great
credit she's written this in engaging
prose and lively prose in ways that
should engage a popular audience and
deserve to find their way to a popular
audience so please join me in welcoming
our nomini on back to campus
[Applause]
well with that I don't know what else to
say like I was blushing it was the
nicest introduction I've ever received
it is a real honor to be here to present
my work with the center of the study of
race indigeneity in transnational
migration when I was at Yale this Center
did not exist and it's really incredible
that it is here now I want to especially
thank nandi Cummings and Steve pity for
organizing my visit this book started as
Steve was saying as a dissertation here
at Yale and it might be the most
exciting moment of my career to come
back in order to talk about it as a book
now here approximately 40% of all
Mexicans from the state of Sakha tickets
now reside in the United States
similarly one-third of all of those from
the state of Guanajuato now live north
of the border and slightly more
Michoacan owes those from the state of
Michoacan now work in the fields of
California Oregon and Illinois then the
number of michoacán o--'s who still
reside in their home state Latinos have
become the largest minority group in the
United States constituting approximately
18% of the population there are an
estimated 11 million undocumented
migrants half of them from Mexico now
residing here the sheer number of
Mexicans who migrated to the United
States and their importance in politics
economics and daily social relations
means that their stories have shaped
both Mexican and US national histories
yet few historians have paid attention
to the causes and effects
of Mexican migration in Mexico and even
fewer have examined how this phenomenon
affected life in both countries creating
strong transnational relations between
them incorporating these dimensions
changes our understandings of both
migration and of us-mexico relations
more broadly my book undocumented lives
the untold story of Mexican migration
examines this history in the postwar
years it does so by using sources that
come from the National Archives of both
countries by using migrants personal
collections which included sources such
as the loved letters that migrants sent
to their communities back home and the
records of their meetings and by using
over 250 oral history interviews that I
conducted on both sides of the border
with people who came from communities
from the states of Michoacana Zacatecas
which I pointed out at the beginning
which were some of the states of highest
out migration using the sources I
examine how unauthorized Mexican
migration became an entrenched
phenomenon in the years between 1965 and
1986 I use these two dates as bookends
to my book because they mark important
turning points in the history of
migration up until 1964 Mexico and the
United States had a bilateral program
through which Mexican workers could come
as guest workers and work legally for
short periods of time in 1964 the United
States unilaterally ends this program
which was called the bracero program as
a result the following year in 1965
mexican workers who are accustomed to
coming here and working find themselves
that they can no longer come to the
united states
legally but their conditions in Mexico
haven't changed and so they continue
coming they simply do so without papers
still their migration is for the most
part circular workers come work here for
a short period short periods of time
return to Mexico and then repeat this
process this pattern of circular
migration ended in 1986 when the US
Congress passed the immigration reform
and Control Act one of the main clauses
of this law was border fortification the
act allotted a lot of money to increase
the size of the Border Patrol and
surveillance technologies across the
border as it became harder for people
for Mexicans to cross the border without
papers they decided to come and settle
permanently because they could no longer
continue to risk going back and forth
now that the border was so much harder
to cross the years between 1965 and 1986
were once in which many of the current
dilemmas around undocumented migration
were born this period saw the
unprecedented rise of unauthorized
Mexican migration apprehensions by the
Immigration and Naturalization Service
otherwise known as the I&S Rose from
55,000 in 1965 to over one and a half
million by 1986 this is over a three
thousand percent overall increase this
period also saw key shifts in the
government policies of both countries
with regard to migration and perhaps
more important it was during this period
that Mexican people's consciousness
shifted toward an acknowledgement that
their future depended on undocumented
migration because of time constraints I
will not be able to touch on every
aspect of that I talk about in my book
instead I will focus on talking about
the broad arguments that I make through
the question of welfare I do so because
the question of welfare alongside with
ones of gender sexuality and
geographical space is because welfare is
one of the main threads that runs
throughout the book alongside with those
other threads now focusing on welfare
today I will discuss two of the main
points that I make in my book first I
argue that during the 1970s
working-class men faced exclusionary
pressures to leave both Mexico and the
United States now that migrants are
excluded from the United States seems
especially nowadays almost intuitive but
that Mexicans were excluded from Mexico
is much more surprising it means that
migrants faced a double exclusion from
the two countries where they lived this
double exclusion was enacted both by the
government officials of Mexico and the
United States as well as by migrants own
communities let me explain this point a
bit further in Mexico the government
stopped policy makers concluded because
that because the nation could no longer
afford to act as a welfare state because
the Mexican economy was starting to
decline it had to it had to find a way
to reduce unemployment and one of the
ways to do so was to encourage people to
emigrate on the other side of the border
in the United States
migrants started to find themselves
accused of draining welfare and they
were regularly deported migrants on
communities started to reject migrants
presence in either Mexico or the United
States on a permanent
bassist increasingly migrants found that
they could belong nowhere that they
could live on a permanent basis
neither in the United States nor in
Mexico they started to claim that they
were from neither here nor there me
Lackey maybe idea now my second argument
is that during this period migrants and
advanced their own visions of where they
belong
by doing so they countered their double
exclusion from Mexico and the United
States in particular I focus on how they
created groups in Los Angeles that
provided Economic Security for migrants
in the United States as well as for
Mexican citizens who remained in Mexico
by guaranteeing that those back home had
their basic needs satisfied I argued
these migrants organization started to
act as a type of extraterritorial
welfare state through this activism
migrants managed to become central
players in regional national and
transnational politics now to make these
two arguments today I will first show
how the US government then the Mexican
government and then Mexican communities
used ideas of welfare to deny migrants
the right to settle permanently in any
place I will then move on to show how by
creating welfare organizations migrants
managed to create their own cartography
of belonging let's start in the United
States one of the main rallying cries
against unauthorized Mexicans starting
in the 1970s was that they were draining
the nation's welfare coffers during this
decade of economic crisis the US economy
saw the rapid rise of unemployment and
inflation simultaneously the expansion
of welfare came to be seen as an urgent
national problem and people of color
were often accused for draining welfare
newspapers often blame the quote-unquote
black promiscuous Cadillac driving
welfare queen for the expansion of
welfare this had this has led historians
to focus strictly on the cultural
associations between black people and
welfare abuse yet the majority of
newspaper articles that talked about the
problems created by Mexican migrants
also refer to the use their use of
public aid and services articles came
out with titles such as illegal aliens
here called public services burden and
welfare system a haven for illegal
aliens Mexicans tried to counter these
stereotypes by blaming us born Mexican
Americans for the existing associations
between Mexicans and welfare abuse for
instance had a Peter Rodriguez who
migrated from Zacatecas held that
everyone in the migrant community
believed that it was us born Mexican
Americans who were abusing welfare among
his friends he claimed mexican-americans
were seen quote as lazy people
we migrants would go to work but those
people generally did not work but
instead survived from welfare this
commonly used strategy of shunning other
marginalized groups did not help
undocumented migrants who continued to
be associated with abusing public
welfare these associations were
particularly unsuitable because
unauthorized migrants were ineligible
for public welfare and few dare to apply
for aid illegally at least six different
field studies published at the time
found that unauthorized Mexican migrants
rarely used public support such as
unemployment compensation welfare
assistance or food stamps
this meant that Mexican migrants were
simultaneously a queue
of draining public resources and at the
same time prevented from applying for
welfare still one of the main arguments
hurt in Congress against undocumented
migrants was of course that they drained
welfare in 1976 those who wanted to
limit the number of Mexicans in the
United States had a clear victory with
the passage of the Western Hemisphere
Act this Act established an annual quota
of 20,000 immigrants per nation from
countries in the Western Hemisphere a
clause that affected Mexico in
particular as it was the only country
with an immigration rate much higher
than 20,000 per year the passage of the
bill was defended in part through
arguments such as those of Thurmond of
senator Thurmond of South Carolina who
argued that quote in many cases these
illegal entrants and their families soon
become a welfare burden on our society
supported in one way or another by
American taxpayers arguments that
Mexican migrants drained welfare did not
simply affect the marking of the border
through legislative means they also
encourage the I&S to increase the number
of raids that it was conducting in
Latino communities in June 1973
Donald T Williams then acting director
of the I n s explained the increasing
number of rates by stating immigrants
attend schools at taxpayers expense they
take jobs that normally would go to
Americans and many of them go on welfare
and use other public social services so
notions of welfare played a significant
role in pushing migrants out of the
United States by encouraging US
officials to introduce legislative
changes to immigration law and by
encouraging them to conduct more raids
against undocumented workers all those
Mexicans kept crossing the border and
living in the United States policymakers
choose them of being Outsiders who
drained welfare now let me turn to the
case of Mexico like US officials during
the 1970s Mexican officials also started
to reject migrants presence in their
country
the Mexican government had a very
different rhetoric on welfare than did
US policymakers after the Mexican
Revolution the ruling party the brief
established itself as a promoter of a
Mexican welfare state but even though
the government legitimized itself
through claims that it was a welfare
state it failed to ensure the economic
well-being of its citizens up until the
mid 1970s Mexican policymakers had long
considered that to achieve a welfare
state and accelerate economic growth
they had to pursue population growth
policies in fact since Mexico's
independence Mexican officials had tried
to increase the number of people who
resided in the country in order to
accelerate the country's economic
development now in terms of migration
what this meant of course was
encouraging those who had already
migrated those who are already in the
United States to return to Mexico while
discouraging others who were still in
Mexico from going abroad in the
mid-1970s Mexico's top politicians
started to change their position in part
because of a collapsing economy during
these years the balance of payment ran a
huge deficit and consumer prices doubled
before leaving office in 1976 President
Teresa Chavarria was forced to devalue
the peso ask for assistance from the IMF
and accept its austerity package Mexican
officials debated how to solve the
nation's economic problems should they
continue to expand the welfare system
even further should they should they
start to change their position
ultimately they concluded that
population growth was no longer Advent
Agis if anything Mexico's population had
to be reduced one way to do so was by
accepting and sometimes even by
encouraging citizens emigration to the
united states now existing government
debt archives contain limited explicit
evidence in which policymakers openly
acknowledge changing their views on
immigration as a way of alleviating
Mexico's economic problems speaking of
such a change would have meant
recognizing that the Breen was giving up
on the revolutions welfare goals of
providing Mexicans with the means of
reciting with humane living standards in
their country of birth it would have
also meant acknowledging that the
government rejected the presence of some
citizens in the national territory and
that officials had started to favor
their departure to a country where they
were viewed primarily as illegal aliens
despite the paucity of such explicit
evidence the jumbled changes in state
practices that occurred between the mid
1960s to the mid 1980s elucidate
politicians changing positions let me
give you a couple of examples that
illustrate how they went from
discouraging unauthorized migration to
viewing it as necessary first from the
mid 1940s to the mid-1970s Mexican and
US migratory officials had coordinated
mechanisms to repatriate deportees deep
into the interior of Mexico these
officials knew that if they released the
deportees near the border region these
migrants would simply cross over to
Mexico the following wave the following
day so the mechanism they introduced
work like this when immigration
officials in the United States caught
unauthorized migrants they would take
them to the us-mexico border and they
would then hand them to Mexican
officials from the Mexican Department of
migration this department of migration
was
in charge of taking the migrants away
from the border and deep into the
Mexican interior and here we can see
officials from Mexico's departamento
immigration department of migration and
a group of men that has been apprehended
and is about to board on a train to take
them into the interior of Mexico now in
the mid-1970s when Mexican officials
started to look favorably on immigration
they stopped attempting to take
deportees away from the border and into
the Mexican Interior this change began
in 1976 when US officials wanted to sign
a 2 million dollar contract with Mexican
officials to be able to send deportees
by plane into the Mexican Interior the
Mexican government for the first time
refused to give these companies
permission to work the government
officials claimed that the deportees had
the quote-unquote constitutional right
to stay in northern Mexico if they so
desired now let me point that before
this point those constitutional rights
didn't seem to matter another example of
politicians changing position is that by
the mid-1970s they started to work on
defending the rights of undocumented
migrants in the United States such
attempts to protect Mexicans in the
United States are not mentioned in
government documents until after
Mexico's top politicians change their
position with regard to emigration the
migratory worker art worker archives
which are all the archives that document
the instances in which consuls assisted
Mexican workers who lived in the United
States as well as Mexican National
Archives all indicate that the concern
over an documented migrants rights did
not begin until the late 1970s when
Mexican officials had started to view
immigration favorably on the contrary
existing government documents show how
before the mid-nineteen
70s Mexican officials insisted that
Mexicans who migrated illegally lost
their right to protection as a result of
their unauthorized migration this
strategy which they communicated to
Mexican workers comes out in the
correspondence that they sent to workers
such as in the letters that government
officials sent to epifanio Clinton on
September 13 1968 in teen son died from
asphyxiation
after his Mugler's left him in a
hermetically closed u-haul truck 14
teens family the tragedy was compounded
by their poverty I said by Fannie oaken
Tina explained to the Mexican consul in
San Antonio he could not support his
wife and his sons children with the five
daily basis that he made as an ice-cream
vendor Indian requested that the
government allow one of his other sons
to go to the United States as a bracero
government officials replied that they
could not allow these other sons to go
to the United States as resettles
because the bracero program had
officially ended but they then added
that they quote considered it convenient
to emphasize that game teen son's not
abandon their residence without the
existence of a legally authorized work
contract as they would otherwise expose
themselves to leaving the country
without the protection of the law
and would run the risks to which those
who break such laws are exposed before
the mid-1970s officials insisted that
migrants lost their right to protection
as a result of their unauthorized
migration in contrast by the mid-1970s
government officials repeatedly informed
migrants of their aims to defend them in
1978 for instance the government
publicly announced the opening of the
first office for the protection of
undocumented workers living in the
United States
this new interest in the human rights of
Mexicans who resided in the United
States is particularly surprising given
the government's blatant disregard for
the rights of citizens who still resided
in Mexico as human rights watch noted
since the late 1960s and early 1970s an
array of abuses have become an
institutionalized part of Mexican
society including killings torture and
abuses against independent Union unions
officials interest in the human rights
of citizens in the United States and
their concurrent lack of concern for
them while in Mexico was related to
their belief that many Mexican citizens
ought to live north of the border after
Mexican officials change their views
regarding migration
they also openly attempted to convince
the United States to allow undocumented
migrants to reside there they even did
so by fanning out cold war fears for
example in 1979 mexico's secretary of
Foreign Relations Jorge Castaneda I
started that the United States was not
giving Mexico special consideration when
it came to immigration given that the
United States was not giving Mexico the
special consideration Castaneda said
Mexico would start looking to Latin
America as well as to quote Europe Japan
the socialist countries in this
not-so-veiled threat he impressed upon
the United States how important
immigration was for Mexico's government
before I continue up to now I have been
arguing that during the 1970s ideas of
welfare pushed forward the view that
Mexicans did not belong in the United
States these notions encouraged US
government officials to deport more
Mexicans and made it harder for Mexican
migrants to enter the United States
during this same decade Mexican
authorities themselves started to reject
the press
of migrants in Mexico while the Mexican
government had previously attempted to
act as a welfare state and continue to
portray itself as such by the mid-1970s
Mexican officials believed that the way
forward was to encourage working-class
citizens to live in a country that
viewed them as illegals now that I have
examined how migrants experienced a
double exclusion from Mexico and the
United States because of the pressures
enacted by both governments let me turn
to the pressures migrants faced from
their own communities at the local level
migrants families and friends also
started to deny them the ability to
recite permanently in either country
because the Mexican government failed to
act as a true welfare state on which
people could rely in time of need
families and communities started to
pressure married men to head north to
support them
Antonio Cordova from the town of Susana
Michoacan recalls that before he started
migrating he went to meet with
government officials to ask them for
credit to buy oxen
according to Cordoba if he had received
this credit and had been able to buy
oxen he would have been able to avoid
going north which he did not want to do
but he recalls that he's got that these
officials just said go I'll examine your
case on this case on this date or that
date but they never did anything without
prospects for jobs and know where to
turn for help
Cordova knew that he would have to
migrate his own family members insisted
that he go to the United States to
support him to support them now from
this example you might have already
picked up that unauthorized migration
and the pressures people fell to migrate
had a profound gender dimension these
gender dynamics often had unexpected
effects in Mexican communities Mexican
men bore the pressures to migrate
to support their families although some
women also migrated to work during the
years between 1965 and 1986 it was
mostly men who migrated and the
community pressure to do so fell almost
strictly on them after all it was
extremely expensive for whole families
to go north in part because of smugglers
fees divisions of labor within the
family led people to believe that men
ought to go north for work in the United
States while women remained at home
taking care of the children
Azmaria radius from no cheese clan
Zacatecas her cause I thought about
migrating but I couldn't because of my
many children I was tired of being alone
while my husband was in the United
States I would tell him take me with you
and he would say how can I take you with
me first where are we where would we
stay were too many second how can I take
you when it's so hard to cross over like
most women but it is never considered
asking her husband to look after their
children while she migrated and remitted
money for the family women were also
discouraged from migrating because of
sexual violence at the border horrifying
stories of the dangers that women faced
circulated throughout Mexican towns
discouraging many women from attempting
their luck in El Northey for example in
the town of Reese Cortinas mitrik on
women warned each other about the
dangers of going to the United States by
telling the story of one particular
village villager whose Mugler had
sexually abused her and according to
them her life had since been ruined
while women were discouraged from
heading to the United States men felt
pressured to do so significantly it was
women in their roles as wives and
mothers who were the main people who
pushed men to migrate for instance Luisa
Garza from noches clan Zacatecas recalls
that many were like that like many women
she insisted that her
spin migrate to provide for their
families welfare because he had to go to
make money to support us he had to work
to be able to provide us with food
because in Mexico life is very hard
her husband's parents and friends also
pushed him to go the staggering rates of
mail migration left many men feeling
inadequate if they did not go to the
United States to provide for their
families migrating to ensure their
families welfare became a way to
establish one's manhood Rafael rano
recalls that like many other men he
migrated with three friends who
pressured each other into taking the
journey had Winona migrated he would
have felt cowardly he says and would
probably would have been ridiculed
community pressure changed the way many
men felt about the space of their
hometown in oral history interviews they
regularly described the pressures they
face to head north as if their hometowns
were shrinking around them and squeezing
them out
Ashley Carla Parris explained everyone
expected me to leave and come back with
money I felt like I couldn't remain in
town without going to the United States
but once in the United States men felt
that their loved ones the very people
who had pressured them to go north in
the first place
now prevented them from reciting them
there permanently once men were abroad
their wives children and parents
regularly pressured them to return home
Roberto Camacho for instance recalls
that his wife and daughter constantly
reproached him for leaving them alone
too much during his stays abroad from
the United States men would receive
letters from their families begging them
to return home soon up to now I have
shown how men came to see their
communities in the United States as
places where they could only reside in
temporarily and their hometowns a spaces
that shrunk around them and squeeze them
out
it is important to note however that
women also saw their sense of space
diminish as a result of men's migration
after going to the United States men
started to fear that their wives who
remained in Mexico would cheat on them
and so started to prohibit them from
socializing outside the home according
to Ana Beltran who lived in Santa Fe de
la Laguna Michoacan villagers often
gossiped about women who socialized
outdoors and they claimed that they were
being unfaithful to their husbands
because rumors of infidelities often
reached del Norte women started to fear
that if they went outside of their homes
too much and rumors spread that they
were cheating on their husbands the men
would stop sending them money as such
many women started to avoid going
outside as much as possible migration is
often associated with a sense of
cosmopolitanism and an opening of
people's worlds but when it came to
unauthorized Mexican migration both men
and women saw their sense of space
diminish in significant ways as a result
of men's migration let me summarize what
I have been saying up to now about the
pressures migrants experienced on both
sides of the border migrants faced a
double exclusion that prevented them
from residing in Mexico and the United
States this exclusion wasn't forced by
government officials from both countries
as well as by their own families and
friends mexico's leaders viewed migrants
as economically superfluous and favored
their departures from Mexico
US officials came to consider migrants
as draining welfare resources and
regularly deported them from the United
States migrants own communities rejected
their presence in either country by
holding that their own welfare depended
on migrants remittances
and return visits now in this context
migrants sought to assert their local
regional and national belonging by
creating their own welfare organizations
to demonstrate this I'm going to focus
on the activism of Mexican nationals and
Los Angeles
one of the main migrant institutions
that work to help other migrants during
these years was the commutative and
efficiency Americana often referred to
in English as the Mexican Welfare
Committee when one examines the
applications for relief that the
committee received a paradox regarding
welfare soon becomes clear as we have
seen us anti-immigrant practices were
often influenced by the rhetoric that
Mexicans abused welfare but these
exclusionary practices themselves were
often responsible for driving migrants
into seeking aid for example in 1970
immigration officials detained 24-year
old
Val de Rosas to deport him back to my
salon Sinaloa on the train ride south
the officers beat him up and confiscated
his belonging fearing for his safety
roses jumped from the Train but he
miscalculated the distance and fell on
the rails the Train severed both legs
and two fingers from his left hand
roses came to require a wheelchair he
couldn't afford to buy it himself so he
solicited aid but not from US state
resources but from the commutative and
efficiency Americana border enforcement
led Rose us to seek welfare aid yet
rather than resorting to US state
resources roses dependent on the support
of other migrants the committee provided
him with the financial support and
wheelchair he needed the committee
became so influential that Mexican
consuls and even the LAPD sent Mexican
Nationals to seek aid from this
organization in other words migrants
became central players in providing each
other with their basic necessities
necessities in the United States the
committee raised money primarily by
renting out a building it owned called
la casa el Mexicano and this is a
picture of how la casa loma he kind of
looked by the mid-1970s the main groups
that rented out la casa were Clouseau
cialis often known by their contemporary
term of hometown associations these
clubs work to send funds across the
border to develop their communities in
Mexico as a result they acted very
differently from the mutual aid
societies that most historians have
analyzed which were to support migrants
within the United States instead
clouseau cialis I argue acted as a type
of extraterritorial welfare state from
the United States clubs took on the role
of the Mexican government and sought to
ensure the welfare of all Mexicans
activists themselves have this
interpretation in his unpublished
memoirs Raul Villarreal who was one of
the main club activists recalls that his
story is one of a simple dishwasher from
a Los Angeles restaurant who by working
in club sociales ended up helping the
people of Mexico more than the
government itself these groups started
as very small organizations in 1962 a
group of migrants from was from this who
was living in Los Angeles but who came
from the small Mexican Rancho of Walla
Luba Victoria which is located in the
state of CEQA
Degas decided to start racing funds to
send money back home and here you have a
list of the first members of this
organizations and you can see it's not
very big there's very few members there
each donating $1 each at a time this was
a very small-scale operation to begin
with
however migrants from other communities
in Mexico soon followed the example of
the club so she al al al Lupe Victoria
and by the mid-1970s a large community
developed in Los Angeles around the idea
of sending aid to Mexico the club
culture that took shape in La Casa del
americano revolved around dances that
happened every weekend and which had
approximately 350 attendees parties
began at 8 p.m. and ended at 2 a.m. as
they rode on people would laugh dance
and converse until the music ended once
the parties finished migrants left with
a renewed sense of community and
belonging the hosting Club with a profit
of approximately $600 Club members sent
the money they collected to local agents
in Mexico who were in charge of managing
the funds for example the clue social
value pair Victoria remitted the money
migrants fund raised to club agents
residing in the Rancho these agents then
distributed it to the elderly on a
weekly basis as the club developed it
started to take on bigger and bigger
projects by 1987 the club had also paved
the Ranchos Main Street fenced it school
set up electric power lines with brought
potable water and built a clinic and
this is a picture of how the clinic
looks today
in other words migrants in the United
States raised money and club
representatives in Mexico ensured that
it was appropriately distributed
together they formed a welfare system
that guaranteed that the ranch was basic
necessities were met migrants felt that
their families and friends prevented
them from settling in either their home
towns or in their new communities but
through their club activism migrants
managed to become central figures in
both these locales from the United
States migrants change the built
environment and living conditions in
Mexico when people walked through pay
streets attended clinics or even flipped
on and turned their light switches they
had to think about migrants
contributions the very meaning of
hometown became imbued with migration
similarly by creating long lasting
spaces where they could gather in the
United States
migrants managed to build a community
north of the border
despite the impermanence of their
individual states their club members
realized that they were taking on
responsibilities that were traditionally
assumed by the state but they argued
that if they did not
the Mexican government would not either
as Gregorio Cassidy just explained the
government wasn't interested for example
it's the government's obligation to
provide what the community needs like
electric lights clinics schools but
unfortunately they didn't do it so we
had to intervene from the 1960s to the
mid-1970s the Mexican government ignored
clubs finally in 1986 Zacatecas Governor
Canada War Eagle realized that given the
huge impact that migrants had on the
state he could not continue to ignore
club activities that year he agreed to
develop a program by which the state
government would match every dollar that
migrant organizations sent to Sokka beg
us for the betterment of their
communities this agreement marked the
first time that migrants were granted
official recognition by a state
government in 1999 the Mexican
government began the program a tres
porno three-for-one by which federal
municipal and state governments all give
a dollar for every dollars club send for
the betterment of communities in 1986
the year that war Rago got involved with
club activities the US Congress passed
the immigration reform and Control Act
which further fortified the us-mexico
border by then however undocumented
migration had already become a south
Pecha leading phenomenon migrants such
as those involved in clubs had learned
that through their migration they could
at least acquire partial national and
local belonging in the multiple spaces
in which they lived
because crossing the border became
increasingly dangerous after 1986 men
started refraining from Circular
migration and instead encouraged their
whole families to cross the border once
and relocate permanently in the United
States they did not dare head back to
Mexico for fear that they would not be
able to cross back north again now
rather than feeling pushed out of all
the places in which they lived and
having a sense of themselves as being
from neither here nor there
migrants now started to feel entrapped
in the United States which they came to
refer to as la haula de oro or the
golden cage my talk has focused on how
in the years between 1965 and 1986
migrants faced a double exclusion from
Mexico in the United States but also how
they managed to assert their own
cartography of belonging through their
activism among other issues my book also
examines how queer men were not the only
world were the only how queer men were
the only ones who could refrain from
migrating it examines the other types of
transnational activism in which migrants
engaged and it analyzes the broader
economic developments that shape the
policies of both countries as such I
offer a transnational perspective of the
history of Mexican migration and the
growth of Latino communities as a
conclusion to today's talk let me point
some of the ways in which of the history
I just recounted sheds light on the
present situation facing undocumented
Mexicans in the United States a growing
number of US citizens are once again
resorting to 1970 stereotypes that
portray Mexicans as draining welfare and
calling for their deportation Mexican
government
officials continue to view with favor
the departure of Mexican citizens to the
United States and even now have not
implemented systems to incorporate those
who are being deported into Mexico's
economy US politicians continue to
ignore how border fortification in fact
increased the number of people residing
in the United States while before 1986
it was primarily men who migrated and
they did so in a circular fashion after
the border became fortified in 1986
entire families migrated and settled
permanently north of the border but this
history shows how by uniting migrants
can improve their conditions and achieve
local national and transnational
recognition and against all odds after
all the years between the 1960s and the
1980s are once which both Mexican
estándar s historians described as ones
that saw a rapid political shift from
the left to the right a decline in
leftist activism and the growing demands
a ssin of the welfare state still during
these years
unauthorized Mexican workers managed to
create their own cross-border welfare
institutions and to fight for their
needs in both countries thank you very
much
[Applause]
thanks everyone and so now I'm I would
love to take some questions thoughts
about the book yeah that that was
forcing people to migrate so these were
historically areas of high out migration
they're areas that experience their
agricultural communities with high
levels of drought so whenever there's a
drought people have to migrate there's
like very little options there are also
communities where during this tar ting
in the 1940s the Mexican government
started to implement what's known as the
Green Revolution where it introduced new
technologies to modernize Mexican
agriculture such as the use of new
fertilizers or irrigation but it didn't
introduce them in every single area so
areas that were not modernized for
example now had to compete with more
modernized areas which was basically
impossible and not only that but the
area that were being modernized often
needed fewer workers so that also left
workers without a job which encouraged
them to migrate especially because they
had also been doing that alongside that
from 1942 to 1964 Mexico and the United
States had this program that I talked
about the racino program which was a
bilateral guest worker program from
which Mexican workers could come and
work for short periods of time much of
the recruiting for that program happened
in those states in the central plateau
region now once you have people starting
to go to the United States a culture of
migration is developed right people
already know how the United State
work they they learn some English they
know where to go it makes it much easier
for them to continue going to the United
States afterwards so in some ways that
help to promote migration in following
years as well so for all these reasons
those those states are the states that
we're seeing highest out migration in
the years between 1965 and 1986 and
earlier as well and later it starts to
diversify to other parts of the country
but what's interesting is that most
people are not thinking about the south
which is a migration that starts later
but they're always surprised that it's
not people from northern Mexico that
were migrating more and part of the
reason that happens is because Mexico
was investing much money in northern
Mexico in a way that it wasn't investing
in the central plateau region in this
western states
any other questions
yeah didn't Gomez can I give you the mic
when the husbands of the wives that left
and the wives were getting or more that
the husbands were getting concerned
about the behavior of the wives that
this sort of intensify an already
misogynistic culture or how did that
shift if any we often have these
stereotypes about Mexican machismo
and it's very easy to reproduce them and
part of what I'm trying to do here is to
say this much yzma some ways is
conditional to the structures that occur
and migration was one of the structures
that was occurring so yes of course
there were some men who were who were
already telling women not to go outside
and stuff but their fear their
insecurities just increased so much they
were like we're away what are our wives
doing let's control them in a way that
beforehand they didn't have so much
insecurity because they were always
around they they were seeing what was
happening right so their insecurities
definitely increased when they were in
the United States and so they started to
increase their control over women now
the way they did it was not just through
them it was through this whole social
world that existed of women in
particular who controlled each other's
movement they controlled it through
gossip and they controlled it because
women often lived in with their parents
and loss so the parents and laws would
not allow their daughters in-laws to go
outside you know so it was a very much
controlling situation when men lived in
Mexico they were the ones in control
they didn't have to rely on their
parents in law and often women
experienced much more liberty they
claimed before men started to migrate in
such high numbers and I actually think
that what like what thinking about this
does is it disrupts the notion that
Mexicans are always machista you know
and show how the structures really
affect gender constructs
thanks so much for the talk and I also
really really enjoyed reading your book
and was particularly interested in the
appendix section about kind of doing
oral history with queer folks and
thinking about queer migration and I'm
wondering if you could talk a little bit
more about that aspect of the project
and how you approach that why that's of
interest and and how that fits into the
story that you're telling yeah so this
project started originally part of what
I was looking at was I was I was just
going around Mexico and I noticed that
in many areas of Mexico there are a lot
of areas that you know had a lot of
women had a lot of elderly people a lot
of men had already migrated but there
was but there was a lot of who your man
and I was like Wyatt why is there such a
high proportion of queer men why are
queer men not migrating so at first it
did not start as an oral history project
per se but simply sonorous observation
and then as I went about it I first it
was the idea of how do I go about
meeting people and it actually proved
much easier than I expected it to I went
to churches churches was one of the main
places where I met people and although
we think of Catholic priests as being
homophobic actually in these towns
everyone was okay with who was gay who
was not they'll be like oh yeah Juanito
burrito you know and they would
introduce me to them do you wanna talk
to me and actually like they would talk
to me and they would be like they they
were fine talking about it and everyone
and everyone else in town knew who was
gay so it was actually there it
facilitated it in larger towns where not
everybody knows each other so much the
people who did know everyone I found out
with taxi drivers taxi drivers because
they circulate throughout town all the
time because they talk they know
everybody I so I would just hop on a cab
and be like and you know sometimes I had
I had to play you know like I'm fairly
like genderqueer looking and so I'd like
plato's like oh like the tide arrived to
like a group of men and I'd be like hey
I'm looking for
gay men like who have you could take me
to that you know I know it's a group of
taxi Stas and I was like who could take
me and there were my god he's gay you
know like I'm they've just I know I
think I like it was the funniest thing
and then finally was like sure someone
was like sure I'll Drive you around I'll
introduce you to people so long as I was
like willing to like take their little
jokes and like laugh with them like and
in the end they introduced and they were
it's not like they were homophobic in
the sense that they were laughing at
being queer as if that was something to
laugh at
but also they were really close friends
with the queer men and treated them with
respect you know so so I would just talk
to people and I found it really strange
how originally I found a really strange
how people were really open about it and
you know how priests were but later I
realized I started looking at more
manuscripts have more archival
manuscripts and I realized that this had
been sort of part of these communities
for a very long time that this wasn't
necessarily new and that gay men
actually had a lot of power in these
communities because as I say in the book
they were able to take jobs that were
very highly paid so women for example
were florists but stereotypes would say
that gay men would be better florists so
they made a lot more money which put
which place them in very economically
privileged situations which in turn gave
them a lot of power in their community
right so that also gave them some
respect
so people were willing to talk about it
thank you also for this this was
absolutely fabulous and sort of going
along with Adams question it sounds like
you had a really rich and diverse source
base and I would love to hear about sort
of the process of going through
everything you found and being able to
craft this and sort of what other
projects you think you could have you
could and will create out of all this
information and you know how you chose
to privilege what information yeah
that's that's a really great question I
went so I was interested in both in two
different sets of questions one is what
was happening at the government level in
Mexico and the United States and one was
what was happening to people that's how
it first started and so it was really
easy to you know like separate the
chapters I was like okay if you started
the archives of the Mexican government
these are the archives and that's how
the book is written and it comes at a
cost another way that I could have
written it is in a much more integrated
way of how people experienced government
policies which I think might have been
more productive so it did come with a
cost and that's another way in which I
could have written it your other
question and oh and then what I did was
like I started incorporating other
dynamic dynamics that I wanted to so for
example activism so I have a chapter on
activism and often you know like things
jumped around like I think the stuff on
from La Casa della mexicana was
originally in Chapter four then it came
to chapter two then I returned to four
and now it's in two again you know so I
really it really did change and there's
many ways to write it but I was trying
to form a narrative that that was a
under to understand for people that show
all the complexities but that was also
readable
for a fascinating talk and a very
important groundbreaking book and I and
I have really appreciate how you
complicate a history of Mexican
migration by centering both the roles of
the Mexican government and the US
government right and I'm intrigued by
your argument about how Mexicans are
displaced from both Mexico and the
United States but also by they look from
the local communities and your picture
like I said my Chicano made me realize
that also while they're being displaced
they find ways to create their own homes
right by telling me that cattle Meccano
the home of the Mexican in this country
there is no ours right so that is most
no servation so thank you for connecting
those points right they have not always
been in the forefront of how understand
making a migration but my question is
about that role of women who stayed in
Mexico so while men were the main ones
who emigrated and we're sending money
back right what was the role of Mexican
women did they had any say or any
leadership roles in organizing how the
money sent was being used to maybe do
the churches clinics or other services
or were they not involved at all
so unfortunately most women were not
involved at all to begin with because a
lot of the money that was being sent in
terms of remittances was being sent to
parents and then the parents in-law
would distribute it to the family
accordingly
so they weren't they weren't in charge
of that money but what did happen was
that in Los Angeles there is this beauty
pageant that is very very important
senorita Mexico Los Angeles it's a it's
a huge panel a pageant the person wins
has a lot of power and one year there's
one woman Mary Ellen a Savannah
who's this this lady over there one one
one senorita many girls Angeles and she
was also extremely charismatic and the
leaders of
socialists realized that she could be
that she could help them raise a lot of
money so they made her president not
just a one club but of the whole
federation of clubs and at that point
she tried to change the position of
women within the clubs now it wasn't
much because few women were migrating
right women were staying primarily in
Mexico but for those women she did
change it for a short period of time she
didn't have much success but for a short
period of time she did incorporate more
women as I'm sure they're part of what
clubs were also doing for example was
bringing people such as my meatus who's
okay but she is a she she's called la
Valentina she's like this woman in the
Mexican Revolution who you know is known
for her gender queerness and they
brought her and she came dressed in male
garb in her in her form so they were in
some ways working with queer gender
presentations and changing gender norms
in that way but in terms of the money
that was sent it was men and the agents
in Mexico who were in charge of the
money were primarily men after 1986
women does do start taking some
positions of power and local communities
but what happens often is that men are
in charge of returning home to be so for
political positions of the heel for
example which are the communal lands
who's going to rule the a heel if all
the men go you'd expect it to be women
but actually what starts to develop in
many communities is that they force a
particular man to return to be in charge
of working in the heel right so so women
don't acquire a lot of political power
in many communities in some they start
acquiring more power particularly in the
state of South Atticus
hi can you discuss the role of children
in your book and like what impact like
moving or not moving and staying in the
in Mexico had and like the role of like
mixed status families well there were
few mixed status families because for
the most part children were staying in
Mexico with their mothers while their
men were migrating right so mixed status
in the sense of more like transnational
more like split you know now we think of
split families when it's almost deported
but back then the split nespresso men
was migrating so you talked to all these
children who say I grew up without a
father I saw him coming and going but he
wasn't there you know for example like I
talked about this this guy Camacho and
you talked to his daughter Karen and she
says I really resented him I didn't
understand what he was going like she
was just a kid and tons of kids describe
the same thing now boys describes
something very different which is that
they grew up knowing that they would
have to come to the United States
now after 1986 of course children start
growing up here children who would have
stayed in Mexico are now being brought
to the United States so when we think
about people who like dreamers right who
are being said you know like all like
the dreamers like actually without Erika
without the fortification of the border
those children would have probably
stayed in Mexico and it's this law that
made it harder for people to cross the
border and continue to engage in
circular migration that led children to
grow up in the United States just give
us a little sense of the material that
you offer regarding struggles for human
rights on the US side of the border in
places like Arizona and Texas I'm
thinking in particular about the work
that you did on the Plyler V todo case
which does get to questions around kids
and the status of kids the rights of
kids and the involvement of parents and
those in those struggles in particular
but you also have some wonderful
material in the book I'm related to
labor rights
for migrants in Arizona and I wonder as
we think about these questions about
well-being if you might just present us
at least briefly with some of them some
of your findings there so some children
did migrate I'm part of the struggle
that started happening in Texas was that
the Texas Legislature decided that
school districts in Texas could decide
whether to allow undocumented migrants
whether to start charging them or
whether or not to allow them at all or
whether to just continue welcoming them
so every district could do whatever they
wanted whatever yeah whatever they
wanted and there's this one district in
Texas Tyler where the principal decided
that he was going to start charging
admission $1,000 for every undocumented
migrant now the kids could not pay that
the parents could not pay that right so
ultimately a group of parents whose
children were undocumented decided to
get together they went for help
everywhere they could they couldn't find
a lot of help originally finally our
church members sent them to MALDEF and
lawyers from MALDEF which was a very
important mexican-american organization
took on their case and you know they
built a case that ultimately was called
Plyler v doe doe because of course the
children couldn't use their name right
that would have been like a form of like
it would be very easy to retaliate
against their families in the small town
of Tyler I'm Plyler because that was the
name of the superintendent of the school
and what was determined and you know
MALDEF put this very important we go
brief and they finally it finally made
it to the Supreme Court and they won and
the judges said yes undocumented
children can attend school but they can
only attend but the reason what that
we're determining this is because it
wasn't quote/unquote it wasn't the fault
of their own what this language does is
that it portrays undocumented children
is innocent andin documented adults is
guilty without realizing the complex
reasons
well and why undocumented adults are
coming now we don't have to fight for
children to go to school we still have
to fight for them to get you know into
college for free like to get the same
amount of grants and benefits to be able
to attend college but we don't have to
fight that for public schools and we
don't have to fight that because of
Plyler video but part of what this law
so does is that it criminalized that it
encouraged the language that
criminalizes unauthorized adults but
this was a very important struggle there
were other legal struggles that came
about one of the ones that Steve was
mentioning was in Arizona at the time
most migrants were not going to Arizona
they were going to California 70% of all
migrants were coming to tell form we're
going to God and from Stanford so now I
mean I always say they're coming here
they're coming together they're going to
California but some some are going to
Arizona especially from states with look
in Mexico with lower out-migration so
one of the most important states where
they were going to Arizona was the
errata for example which at the time
didn't have one of this such a high rate
of migration but every year every season
seasonal workers would come go to
Arizona and work they're now working in
Arizona the jobs that there were two
jobs that existed from farmworkers
working in the onion fields and working
in the Groves in the citrus fields the
onions paid much better and it was much
easier work but undocumented migrants
could not do it partially because
immigration officials were always
circulating throughout Arizona
throughout this area near Phoenix and
they would see undocumented migrants in
the onion fields but the growth had so
much foliage that they could hide within
them so undocumented migrants lived in
the Groves they never left the Groves
they all they always lived there they
lived in cardboard boxes or on top of
branches when there were snakes to avoid
them they drank water that had
fertilizer because that was what was
available the living and working
conditions were absolutely dreadful
so one undocumented migrant
decided that he wanted to organize these
workers he had joined the United Farm
Workers the United Farm Workers at the
time did not support the United Farm
Workers our sister Travis's movement
which at the time was not this is 1977
at the time it was very conflicted about
whether to support and documented
immigrants or not before then it had
been very much opposed to undocumented
migrants so this one organizer lupus
haunches splits away from the United
Farm Workers and decides that he is
going to organize these workers in
Arizona and this in the citrus groves
and the way he does it is he realizes he
can't go into the Groves these are
private properties the workers aren't
coming out so what is he going to do so
what he does is he go to goes to Mexico
and organize his workers in Mexico
itself and he can do so because every
season people from the same communities
in Mexico would come to this field in
Arizona so circular migration is a way
which connects two very different places
and allows him to organize a population
that otherwise would have been
unorganized able and not only that but
by being in Mexico you were asking about
women he meets their wives he meets the
freezer priests talks to them and as
well everyone convinces the men that
it's indispensable that they go and
strike the following harvest season this
is really hard for them because the
union that Lupe Sanchez organized did
not have any strike funds so the men
decide to go and strike decide to come
cross the border and strike even without
having funds this the growth which they
struck that was called Arrowhead ranch
which was partially owned by the
Goldwater family so it received a lot of
media attention and it was the first
successful strike by undocumented
workers so when we're thinking about all
these what you were asking me Steve
about the different forms of activism
there's legal activism around you know
whether children can attend schools
there's labor activism that's very
that's very direct what about what you
know about how to organize unauthorized
workers which at the time had been
considered to be unorganized able and
who were considered to be the strike
breakers you
like oh we don't want to document that
migrants was the the common reasoning
because they will come and they will act
as strike breakers so it was the first
instance when they've said actually we
can organize them and we can do so by
going to Mexico and organizing them
there give you the last word I want to
first thank you I mean we need more the
voices of more historians thinking about
these things were clearly at a moment in
in our kind of collective histories in
North America and which so many of the
issues that you're talking about are
certainly in the newspaper they're the
subject of human rights watch reports
and they're very much on our minds as we
think about the well-being of you know
our neighbors our neighborhoods our
family members and as somebody as a
historian who thinks about this period
between 1965 and 1986 and makes what I
think is a convincing argument that so
much of what we're dealing with today in
2018 was framed by the period in which
the period that you document in this in
this late 20th century moment you know I
want just to ask you to close by saying
a word if you can about how
understanding the history from 1965 to
1986 has shaped the way in which you see
developments today yeah so in some ways
we think about the history of Mexican
migration as thinking you know like oh
they've always come but actually Mexican
migration an authorized Mexican
migration really starts up and continues
uninterrupted until 2008 but it really
starts after the end of the receta
program and the reasons why it starts is
because people had been given an
opportunity to come through the receta
program and that was taken away so part
of what I what I think is important to
think about is how the United States has
historically
cruded people to come created a culture
of migration and then when they no
longer want when the economy or the the
rhetoric you know and they need a
scapegoat they decide to close the door
and to blame Mexicans so that's one of
the things that I constantly think about
the other thing that I think about it's
about how the same stereotypes are
repeated over and over again for example
the idea that migrants abused welfare it
starts in the 1970s because there's this
idea that there's a welfare crisis but
it continues even up to today so it's
just the recycling of stereotypes and
then there is another phenomenon that
really interests me which is this idea
that the way populations look really
change so as I said up until 1986 it was
primarily men who are coming children
were not coming women were not coming
that switches and now when we think
about migration we think about families
we think about family separation in the
sense of deportations in but actually
we're seeing another wave which is that
since 2008 there's a net out-migration
of Mexicans Mexicans are not coming to
the United States when we think about
these patterns more Mexicans are leaving
that are coming and it and that's
extremely important to understand that
these waves you know that these notion
that there are waves of people coming
are just not true like Mexicans are not
coming more Mexicans are leaving and yet
it's as Mexicans you know even though
the populations targeted are now
primarily Central Americans what they
are the ones whose bodies are being
targeted but rhetorically it's still
Mexicans it was still like we still talk
about how Mexico wealth President Trump
still talks about I don't want to say we
do them I'm not talking about that but
how you know like Mexicans are rapists
and criminals and so so that continues
to be part of the rhetoric even though
that is no longer the reality and now in
terms of what I think is the role of the
Mexican government you know part of what
his torus icing has has made me do is
consider the role
the Mexican government and I'm also
extremely interested in seeing what the
Mexican government is doing in terms of
Central Americans who are going through
and that is something that is what I
think we need to be talking about now
how the position of the Mexican
government towards Central Americans has
changed and how you know so part of what
I discovered while doing this this
research was that the United States told
Mexican officials you want Mexicans to
continue coming to the United States ok
then close the border to Central
Americans don't let Central Americans
come because we're really scared of
Central Americans so if you stop Central
Americans from coming we won't have to
take such strong actions at the border
which will also affect Mexicans right so
now we can look at that history and say
why is Mexico still criminalizing
Central Americans when Mexicans did get
criminalized when that didn't change so
that's part of what I'm thinking about
now and it seems to me also I mean one
of your major arguments I guess is that
you know the Mexican government had
historically sacrificed its own
citizenry right in the name of a kind of
modernization project tied to the Green
Revolution and in which it sacrificed
the ideals of of the Mexican Revolution
to which it professed you know
repeatedly in late twentieth century so
perhaps I mean what you may be saying is
that it may be no surprise given the
Mexican government's failure to live up
to the terms of the Revolutionary
Constitution in the late 20th century
that today the Mexican government may be
also engaging in a classist politics
visa vie Central Americans a racist
policy politics via these of the
essential Americans a kind of
modernization project tied to the United
States and a migration project tied to
the migration to the migration of the
United States that it's in a sense does
kind of gesture back to the very period
in which you're discussing that's why he
was my advisor absolutely I did not want
to get myself the last word join me
though in thanking and applauding
thank you everyone
[Applause]
[Music]